welcome to the Halloween spooktacular we
are glad you're here we hope your
costumes are ready and fantastic but
first we have a little special treat for
you a lot of people been asking how did
Steven and I meet when did this all come
together for louder with Crowder and we
have all something special for you now
tune in next week because we will be
telling more of the origin story through
video and you'll you'll want to see that
but uh first this is this goes back to
the first night Steven and I ever met
hope you enjoy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah I gotta get you yeah you're gonna
get the me spectacular special alright
great show for you today
if you can't guess you have to find the
collar make it too tight press it up and
then do that disgusting
says the man covered in Elmer's glue we
have today we have Lauren southern
because you're the recent Vox video
beautiful she calling internationally we
have Kevin Sorbo Kenneth recuse himself
and we have Phil Robertson watching we
also your costumes you can still we've
had a couple but you can still submit
some more costumes a lot of those kind
of themed costumes winner gets an
autographed t-shirt from not gay Jarrod
just so you know Kevin Sorbo had to be
pre-taped that's why it looks different
because that's a way to tape him this
morning he had a flight to catch
producer than me and video studio as
always as Jared who is not gay follow
him on Twitter at not a Jeremy I
described with you thought your comments
your photo shops which are always fun
- Phil my little obligations during
conclusions are we good we're good
at G Morgan Jr the wine man the
sommelier in chief what's the wine of
the day mr. snow Jacob's Creek
finished in a whiskey barrel for vodka
cranberry
the elf who wants to be a dentist for
people who don't know will you be talk
about the Trump dossier and what's going
on with a DNC and Russia this week we'll
be talking about Corey Feldman what else
we can be talking about you can read
talking about what's the question of the
value by the way I forgot to because
usually do a segment yeah you know I
guess the question of the day what we're
gonna be talking more so about Trump and
Russia how just how deafening
would you say in contrast the media's
coverage of it has been it's - it your
anymore I'm finally dumping out like
it's but Louis Newsweek when Italy
so okay we'll get to that doesn't week
comment down below well if you notice
the contrast between the treatment of
Donald Trump and Russia supposedly and
the DNC in Russia actually okay
another news Californians will soon have
non-binary as a gender option on birth
certificates now here's what's important
a lot of people skim through this this
isn't a driver's license no these are
birth certificates meaning parents are
making these decisions for their
children most affected by this of course
will be medical practitioners you have a
beautiful baby
sorry doctor na kijiye was not made
aware of your desired having non gender
non-binary is what this baby is this
baby is free from any and all societal
constructs a bullet no malpractice sued
Bill O'Reilly said this week there's
just no info that he was mad at God
quote over not providing more protection
for him from the recent sexual
harassment allegations which actually it
makes a lot of sense it explains his
latest book released killing God is a
tough one which of course is part two to
his wildly popular killing human
resources no self-control
turns out the no spin zone meant rape
covered man in a thong was pulled over
by police in Oklahoma this is actually
Jerry the police report was Jerry
noticed the man was trembling and
appeared nervous more unusually he also
noticed a nearly empty container of
Vaseline in the car and a pornography
magazine on the seat next to Kellerman
after be bats for identification
Kellerman handed over an oklahoma ID
card with his name on it the deputy then
asked if Kellerman had been masturbating
Kellerman said that yes he had indeed
been he had indeed been I I mean this is
one of those stories where you read the
headline and it's the opposite of
clickbait it's pretty much what you
expect hello sir license and
registration please
were you yes I was masturbating
furiously he didn't read you your rights
it's in the Constitution you don't have
to admit you to master Pretoria you
riveted you have a right to an attorney
well there's there's no need to say
anything speaking of sweet nothings
Corey Feldman launched a campaign to
expose Hollywood pedophilia this is way
he first off before we set this up
because there are critics and it's not
that we think anyone should be a
pedophile in Hollywood I do feel bad for
Kourt Feldman
but this is his video they released on
Twitter here let's let's watch those I
need to protect my family
and you make up our security and I need
a legal team help represent me
so that I can fulfill this mission
change the entertainment system as we
know it and by Tiger blood and I believe
I can also bring down the documentary
yeah a pedophile ring that I've been
aware of since we go out he's acting
right now right off the bat I can name
six names one of them who's still very
powerful today and a story that links
all the way up to studio a studio oh I'm
not going to say which one invest below
the only hang-up he wants 10 million
dollars totally cappers indiegogo 10
Cory 10 million dollars that's Illuma
less did you scrooge mcduck 10 million
dollars you only need $600 worth of
heroin to die
we're home with a Halloween theme
I just it's one of those like I
understand I do feel bad from the guy
right this is clearly someone he dresses
like Michael Jackson yes he does and he
has no identity of a porn star wife -
not a porn sorry I'm sorry she posed and
play with I think maybe and I saw the
wife swap he was trying to act like you
Haffner in it he had these the you know
these love angels he called them it was
clearly a Hugh Hefner ripoff he doesn't
know it it is kind of like indentured
servitude we'd say he didn't choose to
be an actor and he got rust into an
industry of the Weinsteins of the world
and you know I am sympathetic but the
thing is like it seems like he's
treating it more like a an award for
turn these people in yep and say you
know just doing the right thing right
like could you imagine thorn of
disciples knew Judas was the the
betrayer and he was like I'll tell you
if I need some sheep and some shekels
how much you in our little secrets
finally did you pay up first so you pay
up first and like oh and no he already
hung himself you already knew Jesus okay
dang it hey by the way just to clear
this up though hopefully we can clear it
up because here to discuss this issue
happen is we haven't no way the Corey
Feldman himself Corey are are you there
thanks for being here I'm very glad to
be here Stephen thank you sure no
obviously you've heard your critics why
not just release the names of these
predators so that they can't attack
again see that's how you misunderstand
the sensitivity of the issue Steve and
that's why I need you to go immediately
now to my IndieGoGo campaign calm yeah
okay Corey buy me ten million dollars it
you can see how one might think it seems
a little opportunistic you you can just
say whom left did you know no it's not
that simple Stephen this is all part of
a very careful plan you see well it may
be that simple because we have the man
here who admits to the crime himself
well host you actually don't need to pay
a dime for that information it was me I
did a dig molester soon thanks for
taking the time yeah Stephen listen
there's no need to pay him ten million
dollars all over the one dick molester
son who molested corey feldman
okay that is not true and that's why
even to go to my IndieGoGo campaign
absolutely true
even though the VHS tapes to prove it
okay mystery solved I molested corey
feldman hard yeah okay see that seems
pretty cut and drop no it's not which
people can support at my GoFundMe go for
me that times last weekend and Corey's
no no I know they want to hear who needs
the funding no no this is this is
absolutely other trillion dollars are
raised corey feldman and dick molesters
in everybody oh oh god no no and that
went about it alright moving on down the
Cho this is I think the biggest story
from the week also probably the one
that's gotten the least coverage from
see believe it well okay first let's
let's set this up because you've been
following yet well yeah the most central
proof for those who don't know and this
is where the question was have you if
you watch the in if you still have cable
have you heard about cable the Trump the
Russia dossier and its relation to the
DNC and how much comment below we really
really wanted you know I'm not a big
pollster but I'm curious according to
polls because voting for the news were
going why is this not front page so to
set the context the most central proof
of the Trump Russia collusion is
backfiring on the left it was the Trump
it was a dossier they called it right so
this is the one that alleged Trump had
directly colluded with the Russians to
defeat Clinton and it's also where the
more ubiquitous rumors from which they
stem like the Russian prostitutes and
the golden shower real estate deals that
were intended to be bribes yeah this is
the one that BuzzFeed obtained I think
somewhere in January 2017 yes now ever
since then the media has non-stop
embargo I mean listen I don't even tell
you this that Russia influenced the
United States election they're still
interfering in u.s. politics you know
this it's a question of whether Russian
intervention into US politics into high
level top-level US politics whether it's
stopped during the campaign or whether
it is still happening right now
I'm sure the run denier stylist
[Laughter]
they like fly people over and have them
vote in the elections the way they frame
it like they actually voted well in your
place it's funny that you say that
because it turns out then the Washington
Post broke the story this just broke
this week with the Clem campaign and a
DNC had actually funded the Trump toss
Clinton campaign and at the DNC what
exactly did they do well I mean they
have a lawyer and that lawyer went about
looking to hire research when the
interview from one of the firm's example
to get questions GPS perfusion gps
intern subcontracted out to Christopher
Steele the former British intelligence
officer to help get information about
Trump's relationships in Russia those
those reports that Chris field produced
were then passed back to the lawyer who
is representing the Clinton campaign
what we don't really know is how that
information relayed to the campaign our
understanding from talking to people who
are close to the matter is that those
actual steal reports were not directly
handed to the campaign so we don't
really quite understand how the
information was passed who got the
information and and and we you know
obviously we want to know you know what
they did with that information after
they received it I can take a wild guess
DNC officials have repeatedly no never
happened the only thing they like
talking about more than Trump and
Russia's daca Backa Backa and they
continue to deny any knowledge of it
take for instance debbie Wasserman
Schultz daemon and chief right here when
did you worry the DNC in the clinic
every word
and then how can you the DFC of be in
the dark about the dusky arrangement
otherwise you're not really in any of
there's no authority with the DNC oops
or you're really stupid but that would
be sexist we're gonna be presumptuous oh
stop it let's see the sender send your
sexist complaints to the wine man if you
don't know fusion GPS Chris for steel
were heavily connected with the Kremlin
yes Russians participated in creating a
dusty now to be fair the Russian lawyer
who Trump jr. met with was connected
directly with this organization fusion
GPS okay so let's let's let's give that
yeah we use a British special agent guy
to aspire to go do this we couldn't even
keep it made in America miss dossier
point yeah it's crazy America first
[Laughter]
American spy there we go
break the law hi ollie north I'm sure
he's available not so uh now there are
lawsuits by the way being brought
against steel and said secret agent man
himself
court documents revealed that fusion GPS
was feeding the Trump Russian narrative
to the Washington Post Yahoo News New
York Times New Yorker and CNN even
before the election in get this
face-to-face meetings with journalists
it wasn't just like an email that might
have been you know hacked with WikiLeaks
and Podesta talking about meeting behind
a pizza parlor it was actually face to
face this happened even the New York
Times admitted they noted this as of
yesterday
there has been no public corroboration
of the salacious allegations against mr.
Trump nor of the specific claims about
coordination between his associates and
the Russians none no corroboration of
the rumors with President Donald Trump
at the bottom of the article that should
have been the lead what you put this
whole paragraph in the bibliography
smaller fine friends so now we can't say
there's definitive proof to put anyone
behind bars in this case but no
corroboration at all as far as mr.
Trump's involvement we have tons of
evidence that directly refutes the
allegations
president Donald Trump and that is
important considering how the media has
taken the ball and run with it the New
York Times even went on to admit some of
the dossiers claims have been challenged
with supporting evidence that means
[ __ ] for instance mr. Trump's
longtime personal lawyer Michael D Cohen
produced to rebut the dossiers claim
that had secret meetings in Prague with
a Russian official last year so what
does all this mean why does it matter
what are you laughing about the Little
Shop of Horrors over I mean once you
prove one of these things false in this
article doesn't that pretty much like
calling the question everything else
that they're claiming especially yes
that's what's interesting and if we're
gonna play by the left's own rules
they've been claiming all year that
Trump worked on a professional level
meaning exchange monies with the
Russians to directly interfere in the
electorate but but he didn't Oh only one
person did that or one group I should
say the DA's campaign lawyer directly
hired a research firm with ties to Putin
in Russia to create a falsified report
full of information obtained from the
Kremlin to influence a 2016 election and
to subsequently D legitimize President
Trump it's their God and hero Saul
Alinsky would be like you know I told
them I told you to accuse your plot of
doing exactly what you're doing but dear
Lord the story from somewhere more
erotic would be if Trump turned out to
be an illegal Mexican immigrants Alawis
you know it's really all kidding aside
they're actually in some pretty big
trouble with how they handle the
payments for this they actually paid the
lawyers don't use PayPal yeah exactly
they actually paid the law firm and
didn't with the FEC they actually didn't
claim it and so there's some big-time
legal ramifications to that because it's
like twelve point something million that
they paid for this yeah so they're
they're in hot water not just in kind of
a PR sense but they could legally have
some big problems yeah I know right this
is what's incredible to me and again
more important is the media's complete
they're nowhere
again this is an app this is an actual
if you're looking at some kind of a red
flag this is it this is the absences
right here is this way to happen with
President Trump you're talking about
actual just financial ramifications all
your other laundry nice black man when I
paid him a teen billion and you know
what's turning on Twitter right now
front paid 1.75 million or 250,000 more
than the past couple of presidents to
remodel his Oval Office for the White
House
that's what's turning and not this like
this give less of a crap that just shows
you what they're doing like this should
be front page everywhere and it's not do
you realize that Donald Trump blows his
nose with that amount of money
no it's our money that he's spent doing
it it was taxpayer buddy but he's still
doing yeah I know but every headline
these almost 2 million he spent 1.5 and
they they give you the Obama stat like
at the bottom right we have 3 guess we
have to get going but I do want you to
come and I want to see how many of you
knew about all of this go check out the
sources read up on these articles how
many of you knew before this we have
Lauren southern coming up and then of
course a a pre tape with Kevin Stover
than Phil Robertson
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is a tumblr some people might try
to tell you it's a mug
they might scream that it's just as good
as a hand etched mug over and over and
over again they may fill it to the brim
with shekels you might even start to
believe that this is a mug but it's not
this is just a tumbler and asbestos
Laden tumbler
[Music]
Bernard Sanders a man of humble
beginnings from Brooklyn New York a
University of Chicago graduate noted
communist and perennial unemployed
couchsurfer until his early forties you
know him today as a champion for Human
Rights income equality and as the
esteemed senator Sanders helped but
senator Sanders holds a dark secret for
when he consumes his devious
transformation potion he turns into mr.
Bernie
[Applause]
automated by logic critical thinking or
basic impulse control mr. Burney is an
animal of pure instinct privy to his
most primal carnal and selfish urges and
this month mr. Burney has but one
mission one fixation try mug club
completely free of charge for the entire
month of October at louder with Crider
calm slash mug club that's a full
3-month trial of mug Club at louder with
Crowder calm slash mug club because
anything else would be a violation of
Human Rights
[Music]
all right the horrible intro but for a
very lovely lady she deserves better
than this she deserves better than
everything that Hollywood has
propagandists and Elmer's glue you can
follow her at Lauren underscore southern
thank you so much for being here Lauren
we appreciate it thank you are looking
very handsome
I mean creepy but that's how Harvey
Weinstein self described that's how he
described himself when he checked out of
rehab creepy but I don't think they were
that opposed to it come on let's be real
three day rehab for sex addiction thing
so I reached out to you it was last
night oh you've been traveling all over
here in Japan we did a video this week
that that did pretty pretty well based
on Vox and they're sort of soft
encouragement of censorship on YouTube I
didn't realize until halfway through the
video that you were actually giving an
interview to Vox exclusively I thought
they just pulled from your YouTube video
you said oh there's more of a story of
that so do tell right so I first of all
find it I'm such an idiot because I
should always record these things on my
end and I always forget it was a few
months ago actually or something that I
did this interview and I was a psycho
whatever I'll just do a fun interview he
mentions at the beginning of the video
that he put on this queer shirt to try
and trigger me I don't think I could
even see it in the interview we were
doing because just like a shot yeah but
there's one part particularly in that
interview was all cut up completely it
was like an hour long of talking one
part where I talk about Jared Taylor and
he had asked me what I think the limit
is for censorship on YouTube and I was
telling him well you know what sometimes
you see videos where it's just people
yelling racial slurs just yelling the
n-word or anything and that's kind of
that's good like graffiti but why do I
even have it I don't see a point to that
it's not an argument it's not someone
trying to portray something and it's not
really censorship to get rid of graffiti
I still think it should be allowed but
I'd understand if YouTube got rid of it
however instead of those videos being
taken down what you're seeing is
YouTube's sandboxing people like Jared
Taylor who hate him
disagree with him whatever fine but he's
act
making an argument and not just
screaming racial slurs so he just cut
that part of me saying Jared Taylor is
just making an argument I can't believe
YouTube's censoring him instead of
putting it in contrast with me saying
right this whole other about it so he
made me what parts I wondered why you
would do it because the one thing is we
know and this isn't this isn't an insult
here intelligence I was like oh I know I
wish she hadn't done it because I could
have told you that was going to happen
this is a guy who refuses to debate ever
like if there was someone who had a
track record of debating someone you
disagree with right you show up live in
real time but do you think looking back
now you probably probably won't do that
in the future where they have all of the
control looking back I'm gonna record
the entire thing from my end and upload
it because I made I think I did a really
good job representing us but if you're
cutting out every second word I say well
you're gonna be able to make it look
like I'm saying anything just like they
did in this video
yeah like because we've we've repeatedly
and we have racked up millions and
millions of plays rebutting the Vox
videos particularly this guy was it
Carlos Minh Mendez amazing masa masa
masa I don't know gives his parents
heart palpitations that guy and just
blocks everybody and so that's why I was
to know like oh man you know Andrew
Breitbart was a guy as a good example is
always willing to get in and stand and
bang and trade but he always said listen
if you have no control over the medium
at all don't put yourself in a position
where they can make your argument for
you and I could see them doing that with
you when I watch this I didn't realize
until halfway through the video I was
going well that's odd I don't remember
Lauren doing a video on that oh she gave
this guy an interview and he brought
your head
you know my mindset was they're actually
giving a platform for us to present an
argument for free speech and if they're
doing that I can't just say no and not
present our side but you're totally
right they boxed it up they boxed it up
hardcore
what I did find interesting about this
video though is I think they're getting
smarter he kind of portrayed it in a
very sneaky way where he was trying to
be super reasonable but the end
conclusion was still all of these people
our far right and they need to be
censored right but he's he made it more
reasonable so usually those kind of
videos have like extreme dislikes on
them but you they've gotten a lot more
sneaky and smart about how they're
implementing or promoting their
censorship well I think I think they
probably see yeah like you've talked
about Jared though they like to dislike
ratio and they have to try and be like
blocks has always been very sneaky I
think they've always been very good at
hiding their arguments and then in the
manipulating statistical information and
billing data to present their let the
gun control video we debunked you have
always been good at that I can't see the
button disaster Lauren and what you
wouldn't feel so uncomfortable if you
had a wildly inappropriate costume
yourself yeah I understand exactly and I
used to be that way there's like I'm
just gonna go on to anywhere that will
provide a platform and then you realize
you know as you become more popular I
don't have enough time in the day to do
it and you have to make sure that's a
platform where they can't totally
manipulate what it is that you say you
know as long as you have a platform to
present your ideas win lose or draw you
know you can sleep at night
unfortunately Vox has no interest in
doing that which is so funny because
into that in that video he says you know
they have no no duty to fact-check
independent bloggers or face up to big
oh yeah on twitter just like hey this is
this is incorrect
you know I think I'm blocked everyone's
blind he's known for blocking people
okay well he said he had email thanking
me for doing the interview with him so I
think I'm gonna send him an email back
and ask him if he'll do a debate with
you yeah that would be fun to see I
would love to have him on here I think
the reason he conducted an interview you
know Vox has 300 million dollars in
backing people need to understand this
it's not like okay Lauren southern
versus you know bisexual Cuban who
happens to speak at Fox it's Lauren
southern versus 300 million dollars in
backing from eight from NBC and other
corporate sponsors not sponsors people
who are actual investors actual equity
stake holders in the company and they're
sneaky and presenting it as though it's
an independent guy and it's not and just
so people know like I literally forgot
about this interview because it was so
long ago that's how much cutting they
did in this interview that's how much
time they put into stringing together
this narrative I'm like I swear you'll
make a video every day just your honest
thoughts here's what happened here's the
facts they have to spend months
stringing together the narrative
perfectly because they know their ideas
aren't quite right they know censorship
isn't exactly moral so in order to
convince the public it is it's gonna
take a lot of time a lot of money and a
lot of cutting up people's actual words
yes that's a good point and I think it's
a good I think it's especially important
with the left because you know we see
this all the time whether it's Bernie
Sanders or or The Young Turks they see
or we saw us with Bernie exactly we said
he all the facts a majority as though a
poll is a fact and so the left believes
that if a majority of people want
something it is there for democracy ergo
it is the right argument and right now
their arguments as it relates to free
speech as it relates to open a open
speech online I should say hate to use
the term free speech because First
Amendment businesses it gets complicated
it is a losing argument it's an
unpopular argument and that's the first
time for them when they're whole their
whole worldview is based on this pseudo
populism it's tough to realize that most
people don't agree with you yeah and one
thing I would like to bring up with you
cuz they say vloggers independent
bloggers have no incentive to fact-check
I actually think it's different because
you've apologized and I know I've
apologized sometimes for getting things
wrong and the reason is because your
audience calls you on it so you have
more of an incentive than anyone
absolutely well we don't have these one
individual with an agenda that's just
backing us with whatever amount of
millions of dollars like Vox has they
really don't have an incentive to
fact-check when the public don't have to
hold them accountable the public can
scream and whine as much as they want
they can get as much dislikes as they
want and they'll still have their
millions back no I completely agree it's
the opposite the internet will reject
you if you repeatedly give them false
information the internet will throw you
out you will no longer get the views you
did for 10 whoever it is will just tear
you a new one you'll have a million
skeptic channels that'll just rip you to
shreds and it is way you are way more
connected with the people as an
independent vlogger than a lot of these
personalities like Rachel Maddow on the
news it's almost like an above you thing
where people can't go and really send
Rachel Maddow materal emails she doesn't
have patreon backers
really replied to any small critics on
Twitter right it's a totally different
world it is a different matter but
you'll have all those skeptic channels
and people who hate you even if you do
try in fact check yourself so that's it
happens no matter what were you going to
say something jerk I was a big big issue
is that the people who find you an
Internet also know how to use the
Internet want to see them like I knew it
Trump did it all I don't like that
Kirsten powers on Fox News I'm gonna
email the man who sells the gold they
know they can reach you right away who
listen I don't need you to set up a
debate for me and that that's several
steps removed if it happens great people
are always welcome on this show I would
love to see you and him actually have a
conversation in real time because I
think that would be really interesting
where you could maybe ask him about the
things that he didn't include with your
interview I wouldn't bet on it but I'd
love to see that where's the best place
for people to find you so they can
actually watch her independent content
Lauren absolutely I'll try that for sure
and they can find me at more an
underscore southern on Twitter or just
look up my youtube channel Lauren
southern Lauren southern and we have
next I believe we have oh do we have who
do we have next
[Music]
uh now for barely legal with Bill
Richmond sponsored by my club hi i'm
bill richmond the half-asian lawyer with
a louder Crowder here to help clear up
confusion and dispel myths regarding
commonly misunderstood legal terms we
have a question this week from dan for
mississippi dan asks bill last week i
couldn't tell whether we were talking
about being liable or the term libel
because of your thick half asian accent
dan i'm glad to help while some people
would consider me to be from a third
world war ravaged country known as
chicago illinois i think the problem
lies in the fact that you need to get
the [ __ ] out of your ears
last week we were clearly talking about
being liable for civil damages or civil
remedies in a civil lawsuit by
comparison libel is the written
communication of false statements that
harm the reputation of another that
falls with on the under the umbrella of
defamation the other version of
defamation is spoken or oral and it's
called slander so if i were to come to
your house and tell your family that you
have the same amount of IQ points as you
do teeth in your head and if that
weren't true that might be slander i
hope i've cleared up that confusion for
you and for a louder with crowder Cheers
this has been barely legal with bill
richmond sponsored by mug club
[Music]
all right he's a busy man he's all over
the place right but probably not for the
reason that he would like to be but I I
grew up watching him yes you can follow
him at case orbs I've met him a couple
times I don't think he remembers me
because everyone's coming up and always
fawning over him that's what happens
when you are mr. Kevin Sorbo thank you
for being here sir Hotel background that
I'm at right here in New York City right
now I do love the hotel background your
backgrounds a little cooler looks like a
cool little man capable cooler I
wouldn't need to turn man cave just
because legally we're not supposed to
say that apparently sexual harassment
behind the scenes yeah zi cave men and
not men just you know how about i
watched you as hercules and i don't know
if you remember i don't know if was a
spinoff right anything to do with your
show but in canada then there was young
Hercules and it was Ryan Gosling and he
said it was
yeah but he's tiny and so as a kid I
remember being sorely disappointed
did you revisited set and think like
this kid well well he came on the show
as a cadet at the school that I grew up
on that Hercules was trained on as a
youth and so I worked with him and I
remember going on my wife and son I
worked with his kid he's only like 20
years old he's he's he's really he's
good there was something about him he's
got a charismatic thing about him and
then when they picked up the show I
didn't really think about it you're
right back down because he's good shape
now but back then he was a skinny little
kid but I never when the show got
canceled we went out to dinner before
he's come back to America and I would I
said Ryan you're 20 years old you're
good actor you'll do fine and now look
this today yeah he's all over the place
so put on some timberlands give himself
a few inches of height Hercules you know
you're lean he's Lee but you're meeting
you you're about 6-3 I had a friend who
dated him in Cornwall Ontario
I just numbers a kid going like Hercules
come on come on
that wasn't so much concerned with
performance so much as the guy I wanted
to be Hercules hey speaking of Herculean
ability the sexual harassment in
Hollywood you weren't coming on for this
originally but you just told the story I
was in media I was reading this morning
about Versace
actually harassing you it's pretty
blatant the story hand goes you can you
explain it for people who don't know
Stella story because it's funny how it
wasn't was a Hollywood Reporter what was
it at variety I can't remember now no I
did I'm an Adam Carolla Show and he they
want to talk about it to me it's in my
book in the way they write it they make
it look like oh my god it was so
traumatic to me so I I had I had three
nephews in Europe when I was doing the
modeling thing alright so I'm living in
Europe
I meet with Versace he like me puts me
and as fashion shows men and women I
because of my height I'm in the women's
shows because there's six one in their
heels and I'm 6 3 so let's look they
look like a [ __ ] guy walking with
these tall women and then I get invited
to this dinner huge party big party and
there's like 80 people there and I mean
for Sachi and I mean I mean person I
mean I mean I mean Pavarotti I mean
Richard Gere I mean all these people
yeah and I get called another dinner
later on I'm gonna go my girlfriend had
time said you know he's probably gonna
hit on you and I said you know what the
guys already mentioned he likes me from
my from my possibly do this campaign why
not that's what we're out there for
anyway get these big campaigns being GQ
to show that part then I go another
dinner parties about 12 then the 14
thing it says him and myself
yeah that's Ernie that's just that's
just some like private room there are
people all around and all of a sudden
hand goes on my thigh and I said Johnny
come on give me a break you know that
I'm straight you know he goes I know
that's why I like him that's it I'm
attracted to that he said and then he
said he goes in life you must make love
to the dog into the captain to the girl
into the boy you must make love to
everything that's of all about life and
ice laughter is he saying this to me I
said you know buddy all my life I've
been on this road and you're on this
road without missing a beat he says I
build a bridge
[Laughter]
never got his campaign but he's still
friends and is that sexual harassment I
guess it is but I'm not gonna worry
about oh my gosh my career's over cuz I
knew I want to be an actor anyway the
whole modeling thing only because I was
dating a model at the time happen I was
gonna move to LA from Minnesota but this
was a sidetrack of my life which I don't
regret because I got to spend three
hours in Europe and it was kind of cool
to see how socialism can destroy country
and na kijiye was just there for the
first time recently he was a kind idea
this is nono much a beautiful city to
visit nobody just a spirit of brokenness
and socialism and taxes are up even more
the sales taxes from when I last left
because Harper was still Prime Minister
when I lived there but I do find it
interesting it was like the Pepe LePew
you're like I'm straight yes and here's
one thing I will say that I really
respect about this because if you okay
just so you know that's sexual
harassment
alright I appreciate your plain clothes
because these are celebrities out now
who talk about the sexual harassment but
they talk about it so it's traumatic and
then they don't name names whereas you
you were very nonchalant about it like
yeah listen this happened Versace if I
don't let him would have reached up grab
my balls I told them not to I didn't get
the gig but you named the name and you
didn't play the victim
it's have you noticed it's a stark
contrast to everyone else coming out
like nobody ever says I did it whether
it's once it's 20 years later it became
really distraught over it yeah 20
Twitter's later all of sudden having
PTSD flashbacks this is very unique in
the way you presented this story did you
notice that well I think yeah I think
it's like this thing it's funny how that
you mean I'm sure that I'm gonna get
people coming at me now and I'm gonna
laugh at it cuz it's a joke it's in my
book true straight it's in the book
check it out I'm not blasting I'm not
being mean to him me what I eat to me
it's like I I respected his talent I
love the suits he kidding me the best
suits around saachi's so it was it was I
just thought I just think it's kind of
funny but you know they're gonna take
anything if you have a different point
of view from a if you're a conservative
and they're gonna blow it up and make it
look like even though they'll do the
same thing but it's ok if they do it but
I do wonder why now they bring it up it
like you said if it's in your book why
didn't anyone care back then was it just
because you know straight white all male
you think it's the ban bit in well they
didn't read my book except for Sachi
give you had it by his nightstand other
projects I've heard this you know having
been an actor for a good portion of my
life before star doing stand-up that
more male models are straight than
actors it's actually rare for male
models to be gay it's usually actors who
are gay I have no experience clearly in
the male modeling world was that was
that your experience it's just an aside
um I don't know what the stats are but I
don't disagree with that because I
almost pretty much every single guy that
I met over in Europe in Italy and in in
France and London wherever as far as I
knew they were straight there was only
one guy that told me after about a year
goes by the way I'm gay you know what I
can't disagree with that and wouldn't it
wouldn't wouldn't surprise me
yeah it's like male cheerleaders that
they're the straightest of them all
they're the smartest I'm so sorry guys
are brilliant when people used to mock
george w bush like use a male
cheerleader like did you see did you see
the ladies okay so we can move on from
this I'm glad there's no post-traumatic
stress with for Saatchi you can send him
my way I'll build a bridge if he gives
me some suits Dream of Jeannie and I met
Bob reading years ago I told her I was
only like seven when I watch his show
and I knew I had no problem my sexual
identities yes exactly the poster not
gay Jarrod was just looking at the Red
Power Ranger thinking okay this is my
kind of this is my back just tell us
about your
have a ton of time but your latest
project you know let there be light a
lot of people now who are younger who
maybe weren't introduced to you with
your previous work like Hercules this is
kind of how they've come to know you and
a lot of faith-based works what was a
transition like and then of course that
leads into let there be light you know
wasn't really a transition I mean I did
I did Hercules seven years which was
certainly a family-friendly show that I
did in drama - five years up there in
Vancouver and the BC for five years
loved it and then since I'm shot over 50
movies is fine 15 I wish I didn't do but
I move you back in 2011 called what
guess and it was by the pure flix guys
the same guys I did a really successful
movie with them called God's not dead
right it's the soul sir for the Bethany
Hamilton story so that's kind of a road
I didn't wasn't planning on going down I
am a Christian I'm a conservative but I
wasn't on purpose I'm okay now I'm just
gonna do Christian movies but once I
came out of the conservative closet the
tolerant role of Hollywood stopped
calling me
ya know the ones who's in for tolerance
and so I've stayed alive doing you know
independent movies this movie left every
light is just an amazing movie my wife
wrote it co-wrote it with Dan Borden Dan
Gordon is a big Hollywood writer he
wrote the hurricane with Denzel
Washington D wrote the passenger 57 was
he Snipes wider but Kevin Costner they
came in wrote this about less than two
weeks after I read the script I get a
call from Sean Hannity and Sean says
Kevin I want to do a movie with you I
like your faith-based movies do you have
one yep we got one flew to New York we
pitched them you're going to check right
then they're less than six months later
we're filming this movie and now it's
done and it opens it opens this week and
he's not he's not starring in it correct
Sean Hannity is just he's he's in the
movie a little bit as themselves okay
that might be a little rough because I'm
juggling [ __ ] with John no I'm the lead
in it and my wife the female lead in it
and actually my two boys who I'm gonna
call to come in here cuz you have huge
fans with my Tucson oh jeez I'm watching
somebody else Kevin get them water get
him in a room before Saachi for all I
care build some bridges for the love of
God
turn the dial this this is a great movie
people go to go to let
there'd be like movie calm let there be
like movie conquers okay we're
independent film we're three million
dollar movie alright that's like that's
like catering on Pirates of the
Caribbean we don't have 150 million of
dollars to throw out there for all these
promotion stuff so people stop me all
the time used to because of Hercules not
least at Meal Time because of my
faith-based movies please make more and
I said well then you have to support
them so please go to let there be like
movie comm support the movie if it's not
in your town you can go to the feet and
say we'll fill this sucker up and
they'll bring it there I promise yeah
and a lot of people are doing that again
it's let there be light it comes to
theaters or if it's not in your theater
this Friday and yeah but I want you know
we'll have you back and talk about that
because we have Phil Robertson on
today's show as well it's to get and he
knows this all too well coming out in
the tolerant left they went after him so
it just so happens at your two stories
of course one that's left there be light
film atcase orbs let the relight movie
calm damn it I ruined the plug I'm
trying to build bridges I'm not as good
let there be like frightened look at it
rims movie playing my son there you go
you make you make good-looking children
it's another skill you're you're you're
just full of male modeling and acting
and making humans we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey there handsome
no not not you Oh Lord no I'm talking
about that snazzy t-shirt looks like
someone's been dropping some coin at
louder with grotto shop calm now come
near let the world see don't be shy
there we go that's what I'm talking
about oh no someone's trying to be a
sneaky fellow
let's go we're that bad boy loud and
proud nothing to be ashamed of here hey
what's the big idea stop kidding around
and show everybody your swag don't make
me come down there well now your t-shirt
just says socialism which is far more
embarrassing there we go see nothing to
be afraid of available exclusively
louder with Crowder shop calm mug
clubbers are almost never beaten up for
wearing a long-sleeve socialism is for
[ __ ] t-shirt unless of course you're
sickly looking and lacking
self-confidence and that's why we now
sell long-sleeve versions perfect for
those cool summer nights and covering up
a lifetime of Jim avoidance and for
decisions get yours now with Lada with
Grutter shop car that's louder with
Grutter shop calm because anywhere else
would be pure factory
[Applause]
[Music]
so October is wrapping up Lars
credit.com / mug club it is mug club is
a human right month it's the end of it
you could have been trying it this whole
month but you can still try there's time
left actually I think a seven-day trial
goes at this point either way you're
getting seven days but a lot of credit a
Komsomol Club for those who miss you see
the clips every day on YouTube we do a
show every single day it's also what
keeps everybody employed unfortunately
even not gay Jared it's 99 annually 69
for students veterans are active
military we're gonna blow past a million
subscribers on YouTube here the only
completely independent channel I don't
know we don't have multiple shows in
this channel it's not like Young Turks
oh there's some other conservative
channels that have you know many chant
many shows in their channel we're
begrudge those people for that but this
is the only show on this channel we're
doing one video a day five times a week
and the growth is entirely because of
people like you who subscribe to join
the Mudd Club
it is the paid content that allows us to
continue releasing more and more free
content we appreciate it so much and
listen the more you keep joining the
more will grow and we'll fight back as
best we can and if you don't I'm gonna
go molest the umbrella tree let's be
honest I'm gonna do it anyway
ladders how did I come / mug plug
[Music]
glad to have our next guest now before I
bring him on I want to run a clip this
is for people out there if you're a mug
club or if your subscriber to see our TV
it's the latest show announcement you
guys know them of course that's happy
happy happy from duck dynasty notorious
or just famous depending on where you
line up let's see a clip of this now
available for people at CR TV never tell
your story
I'm driving home and I see a dark object
in the middle of the road
there was a grizzly bear just stalking
him all I saw was a white flash come at
my face huh and then I back down
the woods they're always quite there's
no one here but me
that looks intense looks fits like
breaking bad ass looks like Breaking Bad
with major killer robertson goes on a
drug screen well no I I highly doubt it
but you can follow them on the Twitter
at duck commander PR Missa the the
leader of the Robertson family mr.
Robertson Phil Robertson how are you sir
good well we're glad to have you here so
this show looks it looks intense now you
obviously kind of took a hiatus from
sort of I guess broadcast your own
programme after duck dynasty what made
you want to come out and do this and how
is it differently what are we going to
see from Phil Robertson that people
haven't seen before that it's now
unfiltered well my oldest son said dad
it's it when someone catches you on a
cellphone and you say a few words or
offer a little advice we noticed that
usually there are a lot of people who
respond to that as in millions yeah he
then said therefore dad you need to talk
more and I said well figure out how I
can do that show it to me and we'll talk
it over you have to remember I'm not
computer savvy I've never been on the
internet me knowingly yeah click down to
it I don't fool with that nor cellphone
so I'm sort of illiterate when it comes
to cell phones or computers
well there probably aren't a ton of them
out in the woods but that's got to feel
good most kids are not telling their dad
like hey Dad I need you to talk more
much shut up so that's kind of good
little unusual but I said okay let's
talk more I said hey figure out if we're
gonna do this figure out how you get a
little revenue stream and we'll try to
get a few words out to America I think
they need a few so yeah well they took
it from there that's an important point
because a a lot of people who want to
hear what you have to say duck dynasty
sort of Rhett I will tell you this I
don't have cable
ok so kind of like you with television I
was not a viewer of duck dynasty because
I haven't had cabled my entire adult
life I stumbled on it accidentally
actually the day after my wedding so we
were this is where we were waiting
before he left for a honeymoon we were
in a hotel it was rainy there was it
much to do
and I watched it and I said huh it's
just a reality show where people are
decent and then I hit me this is very
bizarre it's a reality show where people
are decent and that's where it
registered with with a lot of people and
then you were run out on the rails from
the entertainment industry too and
putting this in quotes here simply for
being decent do you feel like you were
he was kind of a landmark there because
it was really striking how most of
America reacted to your comments versus
the publications and in media well the
guy walks up to me and in a magazine
interview on how I got started and he
asked me that I believe homosexual
behavior was a sin and I quoted first
Corinthians 6:9 and 10 will be to see
neither the section tomorrow there are
doctors the adulterers the male
prostitutes the homosexual offenders
thieves greedy drunkards slanders or
swindlers will inherit the kingdom of
God and I just let that that was my
answer I just quoted a Bible verse
amazingly it was it hit the news media
that I was a low-down sorry
good-for-nothing and I basically was
thinking well there argue with God here
I just gave him a Bible verse but the
news media didn't know it was a Bible
verse so two weeks later they finally
find out it's a Bible verse about that
time by that time the public when I got
fired they told me later they said mr.
Robertson we didn't actually fire you we
put you on what we called an indefinite
hiatus yeah I read that I said I looked
up hiatus and it said a gap in the
proceedings I said I think you sent me
down the road only in Hollywood is 2000
year old information shocking think the
Weinsteins could get on that like hey
listen it seems he was quoting a blogger
named Corinthian second I'm not sure can
someone get a fact-checker on this and
they don't have to say is be careful
when you quote Bible verses in America
because you can hit the road in a
heartbeat
well but what surprises me is this
wasn't this wasn't news and it sounds
like anybody who know knew
duck dynasty you were you're a Christian
conservative family I mean it's pretty
obvious if not from the beard let's be
real here by the way congratulations I
can't grow one but it's pretty obvious
it just seems as though this was again
selective outrage the magazine right I
think it was GQ it might have been
Esquire I don't know decided oh this is
I'm gonna avoid swindlers and thieves
and regardless of people who've been
watching right now whether they agree or
not said oh I want to pick the outrage
today that Phil Robertson has a problem
with homosexuals no one who would have
watched the show this is why I think
it's so important people to see your
show and subscribe there at Sierra TV no
one who watched duck dynasty was
offended by it that's what's so weird
yeah not a talent so you have to
remember what's amazing is everyone was
shocked after all the smoke cleared
because they said mr. Robertson did you
hear from any group the other nine
groups if it's man ten sins but the only
the homosexuals hollered and I was
thinking well look like Washington DC
but of commish swindler slanderers but
they didn't call so I'm thinking right
maybe I didn't hit them all the Clintons
have that in a dossier let's just so now
you have the show into the woods what
can people expect with this like how is
it how is it different from duck dynasty
because obviously that's this this major
network where whether you guys want to
say things or not it's pretty apparent
now there were things that they didn't
want to be broadcast what can people
expect when you just go into the woods
you just gonna shoot stuff and say
things no this could be a little more
intense you have to remember in our
culture today there there's there's so
many divorces there's so many broken
homes miss Kay and I everyday deal with
people that I noticed Trump today is
declaring war on people on opioids well
miss Kay and I we deal we go with to the
rehabs to the prisons and to all the
people who come from all over the nation
right they drive down they hitchhike
down
get on a bus and come down we counsel
them and we tried to get them though
where they turn away from drug use
opioids heroin crystal meth so we on an
ongoing basis these are the people we
work with we point them to Jesus since
they looked you can be forgiven I know
you're in the rehab what you need is to
be redeemed instead and along with
rehabilitation there's a difference
notice I'm trying to get him and you can
only do it right the people you're
dealing with are again the people you
would list from that corinthians verse
swindlers steelers drunkards all of
these people and you can only help them
you can only help them let's get rid of
even the spiritual side for people who
watch our atheists let's just talk
rehabilitation if you recognizing first
step acknowledging a problem that would
mean I'm a thief I should probably get
[Laughter]
salt water made us I'm like so water so
we begin there and we just Maura found
you liable to see like a guy like a
astrophysicists he'll be riding along
with me you know and we'll let the
astrophysics I know some so you got a
remember I'm a c-plus man but every once
in a while I run what I run with a plus
man just to hear what they have to say
well you're selling yourself short
cuz I've heard some stories about you I
mean even football people have to pull
that out it was a monster a monster for
people who don't know a lot of our
audience they're very young they don't
know how you act you know Terry Bradshaw
ended up afterward only being fortunate
enough because of your spot that was
vacant you're very humble in this you're
much much smarter and also a much better
athlete than most people know remember I
just concluded that it would be much
safer to chase nuts than to have large
violent men chasing me you understand
what I'm saying I do understand but I
know the coach was none too happy about
it because the trace is not isn't the
chase is not the problem it's when they
catch you that's when the problem comes
up yes I can imagine and then you can't
be an astrophysicist because even clock
in the head one too many times in fact
there you go maybe there you go we have
leather helmets which meant your
protective you would think about that
chair do you think they got on that
quicker like honest leathers not really
predicting them from that 300-pound man
already
mr. Robertson we do have to get going
here and in wrap this program up today
where is the best place for people to
watch and follow this new show I know
some folks are excited see our tv.com
that's what they told me to say remember
computer illiterate you're trying to get
these words down comp and all this kind
of stuff yeah somebody asked me by the
way how do you function without
operating a cell phone or a computer my
answer is very peacefully yes I can
imagine
when people say yeah you know it fills
out it fill can't be reached right now
Oh buddy has it on airplane mode no no
he ears airplane mode so jealous that's
it all right well you know what it
probably comes with it comes with a lot
less complications that is at duck
commander PR you can watch it on see it
to be for Michael members and
subscribers
mr. Robertson thank you so much we
appreciate it brother and we're gonna
wrap this show up because there's some
music
[Music]
[Music]
human right money you can try it for one
night absolutely free those sons of
[ __ ] and filthy [ __ ] in the 1%
can't keep it all themselves try mug
Club completely free of charge for the
entire month of October at louder with
Crider calm / Mudd Club that's a full
3-month trial of mug Club at louder with
Crowder dot-com / mug club because
anything else would be a violation of
Human Rights
[Music]
[Music]
thank you so much Phil Robertson Kevin
Sorbo Lorne Southern by the way what is
who is sound guy Edwards sound guy ever
no get back they're getting ahead word
is a nun named Hager come on yeah of
course he is okay yeah what I thought
just reminded me you know being that
Venus fat is Harvey Weinstein the
floating problem when I was a kid hear
all those like floaty belts or those
yeah yeah they're awesome I stole you
can talk to you don't interrupt my
closing except you can talk now
I was I was told that - no don't this is
your quali and look like a gay Middle
Ages you're those floaty belts when you
were a kid
yeah like around like they're the most
dangerous thing I can think of I
remember as a kid it just you have to
kind of swing yourself tip over and then
you're upside down with your legs
kicking and there's no way to get back I
lost six right it's true yeah Jared's
got to turn them over by the water and a
fern the Fern Gully mascot should not
have gone that way so Larry you deserved
more okay this is a start people been
asking me about and by what we just
tweet it we tweeted out who was the
winner for the the costume contest we're
disappointed you couldn't do more no
Bernie Sanders was on my flight we went
to Burlington Vermont to shoot a video
it's not out yet and Bernie Sanders was
on my flight you can see here this is
this is him and it's just so iconic he
was sitting right at the he was priority
boarding and seated right look at the
drape the dividing line between first
class and him and he knew that the point
of pride for him he's basically in first
class without the snacks and every time
they came he by it was like the free
drinks she still was on his iPad and he
did this use a hmm you try to go back
nine
you can't resist like tipping his feet
over the line a little bit like no mom I
said he had no carry on
no carry on no check back but he also
can have a briefcase so no work was
being done flying out from Burlington to
DC I should say had a layover in DC it's
normal and I you know I texted you guys
on like hey he's on the plane oh my gosh
you have to do something you have to get
us you have to mess I'm like I'm not
gonna mess with him you have to get a
selfie so I change into my socialism's
for figs shirt naturally in the in the
airport by the if you've never changed
an airplane bathroom guaranteed way to
end up playing tommy-gun you have it
just at the hey my check it was in my my
carry-on so I put it on and I was
planning on just getting a selfie with
him this was the night after the Ted
Cruz debate and I just I couldn't he
walked off the plane and I tell it was
like a painting it was so sad everyone
walked one way and he walked down this
hallway and it wasn't like it was a
hallway that we you know he was there's
no there were no no guards around him he
just was walking alone and the guy was
walking alone down a hallway able to
move you go trigger shirt for nothing
yeah I can't do it cuz it's it's like
it's like finding your it's your
fiercest rival and he's he's you have
the dagger and he's just sleeping yeah
midnight he was tired of years thing I
don't hate Bernie Sanders I really don't
I think his ideas are wrong I think his
ideas stem from an evil ideology suck
but I would much rather host him on the
show or have some kind of a debate it
doesn't matter who it is I wouldn't go
off and just harass somebody almost have
been somebody who would harass me first
but anyways so Bernie Sanders was on my
flight and they love you'll think missed
opportunity I think you know I'd
probably be upset if someone just came
up to me and in sandbagged me but then I
go back and forth thinking what you know
he also wants he wants to take all my
stuff you tell me what you thought if I
should have done something I have to be
there I just felt so bad from you just
like it was like yeah I mean I'd be like
even if kim jeong-hoon were here you
know like I would I still like I
wouldn't like him but it wouldn't be
like ah piss off Kim
and kick him down a cliff I still profil
Becca's he's so little I think shanks
the only guy that you would do that to
well Jake I was on the other hand forced
my hand and I talked about her Joe Rogan
I was I can't I'm never gonna do that
again I felt bad doing it Jared knows
that yeah but he had called me out
before and then offered no recourse with
rebate I thought it was so cowardly this
was the only way it could ever happen so
that was a very special situation and
people know it anyway this also ties me
to something really sad you know we were
in Montreal recently this was your first
time there first time what were you
surprised at all when you went because
this was your first time and you did
seem surprised I was surprised
particularly I mean just aesthetically
it felt so much more like Europe it just
even aesthetically you know much less
culturally speaking yeah so I thought
that was really interesting I mean
they're so close to the you know what
like 40 minutes into the into the border
yeah it's like were in Europe and ten
minutes from the bless' than ten minutes
when we stopped to that place to
exchange you know exchange monies they
didn't speak a word of English not a
word of English from the Vermont no
really crappy yes you know why you
you're so fixated all like nice gas
stations because this was how small your
world must be and that's why when people
say oh but they love their health care
more yeah but these are people who live
ten minutes from the United States I
know who never learned the language
where to ask them they would say I'm
happier only speaking French and not
French so even people in France
understand mind you only in rural Quebec
says what they had to understand those
people who live like ten miles into the
border I'm like why wouldn't you just
like like why are you here yeah it was
fun I understand it for we clocked
aboard on the way back yeah it's just
four miles before no sense of he's like
why would you you you don't speak a word
of English and you're paying half your
salary your your minimum wage salary in
taxes you don't know how they do it I
can tell you exactly what it is and
that's that's kind of what what I've
been deliberating over this week is um
enough enough good enough is good enough
yeah and that's the big difference
between you and people talk about I just
watched a debate recently I came here
who it was they're talking about
conservatism versus liberalism you know
going back to to Quebec to Montreal
great foods and beautiful areas but you
would probably say being there I would
have much more in common being raised
with someone from Europe than most kids
in the United States oh yeah by far yes
certainly more than anyone in the US
yeah yeah and I definitely when I moved
to the States it was my
more of a culture shock than I would
even say I would say where I was raised
is much more similar to Ireland when we
visited than it would be to say Texas
certainly culture of people the culture
the kind of you but it's a culture of
good enough is good enough and these
people don't learn English they're
living right beyond the border I had
friends there who just like David just
seemed so broken over being in this
place taxes have gone up you know sales
taxes and it's one of those issues these
people have never thought of it and
that's why I always say when you it goes
back to any time people get into Bates
whether it's Ted Cruz and Bernie Sanders
or recently Cameron who was some kind of
a youtube debate saying well actually
people in these countries when asked
much prefer their health care
well yeah but these people also are
paying sixteen percent sales tax and
they're still paying for seventy percent
of the drugs they want if you ask anyone
if you ask someone in Quebec saying hey
are you happy or not speaking English
are you happy that you've never been the
United States of America a majority that
we're going to say yes that's a
subjective question it's about giving an
opinion the fact that a majority of
people give a specific opinion doesn't
mean that it's good it doesn't mean that
it's right and also we talked about this
with your like some of your friends you
noticed there's a big difference between
the people who know at people who don't
know people who have kind of in red pill
and like you know what I I'm they're
they're broken because they know this
doesn't have to be this way they know
there's a different world out there and
they've seen in they tasted that's why
we you know like spend content computers
and computer the same but LaPlante is
heavy it wears it is this is that's
higher yeah when a guy came up when we
were there a few people who came up were
fans we thought oh no Montrose is for
sure they're gonna be you know trying to
to punch a bunch of passionate fans like
cuz they listen I know man
I know I mean no one here my family
doesn't get it and and that's what we
say to a typically our average viewer is
is that you guys are good
I typically Ravager is a male 18 to 35
when we get a woman who comes up they
are very very passionate I get the
Gosnell play still going on in New York
City by the way how they recommend you
go check it out also Owen Benjamin's
recent stand-up special I promise them
on get their plugs and or when we have
when we were in New York every single
person who came up was either black
Latino female one was gay they tend to
be the most passionate and a reason for
it like we've talked about this they go
against the grain and with Montreal
essentially needed the term red pill
again they will go through there and tie
lives it's a it's a culture of leisure
not a culture of productivity at all
it's why everything just gets a little
more worn down we think it's quaint we
think there's more history we think
there's more culture it's just that
they're old crap looks just like they're
new crap that's the thing everything is
old crap i sat and I spoke the lady at
our hotel in Old Port Montreal and she
was from France and I asked her what the
tax I think it's 16 percent of in Quebec
if I'm not mistaken when I left it was
lower because of Stephen Harper and now
it's back up
she said yeah you know that's you know
it's kind of expensive but it's not that
bad I said well what's your income tax
like and I was in some some around 52%
something like that that's a deal in
Texas we in Texas there's no state tax
there's no state tax at all she's like
oh really when you buy something I said
no no there's no state income tax she
said what so there's no state income tax
in Texas I have a lot of family in Texas
none do you mean then your income like
when you get your paycheck yep none I
said nope and they have a surplus how is
how is that I'm like how is that how do
you think that is I don't know I would
think they have like bankrupt do you
know we die here of the debt I go yeah
well think about it people have more
money to spend we have nearly
non-existent unemployment and there's
more disposable income and so actually
the government makes more revenue in
taxes when you give people the freedom
to choose what they can do with their
own dollars you say oh I never think of
it like that you know I want to travel
so much but that I never think I have to
go to Texas now and that's the thing it
is really important for you this is why
I say the prism through which you look
at the world determines first off what
is right and wrong because this is
effectively an act of force 52 percent
income tax right it's it's nice that you
want things paid for but it's not an
actual realistic it's not an actual
legitimate role of government it can
only be done through force we've talked
about that but people who don't think of
these issues once they start thinking
about them will their minds will begin
to change that's where you see you know
we talked about this to change my mind
that segment that went up we were so
surprised and I'm so happy and proud not
of me but of the fans who watch the show
that that is is edging up on a million
place it was me sitting down for 20
minutes you haven't watched it letting
people come up and change my mind it is
the opposite it is antithetical to cable
news it
the opposite of soundbites it is speak
and let me hear you out let me get you
to question your own position and people
start changing their own minds and it's
very different from when we had a debate
this week a constant came on from
TechCrunch or he came on hostile he was
ready to defend his world you because
this is what this is what I've got I've
got to be glued to this I bet I stay
with this because my paycheck has
beholden to it but those people change
my mind they've never thought of these
issues these kids in college they've
never thought of where Wright comes from
people in Quebec have never thought
about the fact that when you give people
more freedom you can actually make more
taxes and revenue people in Quebec have
never thought of the fact that it is
absolutely
here is something morally reprehensible
for Canada to rely on the United States
for its national defense when we talk
about North Korea and if they could have
a missile hit United States mainland
well before that Canada does Canada have
a defense system no who do they rely on
the United States so they're you they
literally rely on the they can have
socialized health care at 52% income tax
and paying for 70% of drugs that you
want because they which is morally
completely repugnant depend in the
United States for their national
security and no one thinks of it no one
thinks of it I was talking with people
in Canada saying hey what do you think
what do you think would would change if
you had to pay for your national
security this person said well you know
I can't I can't believe United States
spends so much in its military and they
can't spend on health care it's just
it's absurd so what do you think would
happen if there would be some kind of a
war to break out with Canada so what do
you mean I said let's just use North
Korea is an example I know they're not
really a threat but if they're talk
about sending a missile over right let's
just get past qualms how would Canada
defend itself
well that's we have a we have it were at
the United States or our allies right so
do you think it might change your
country's economic outlook if you had to
pay for your own when it comes to
protecting yourself can you see how
maybe it expiated States they think
we're arrogant no I think it is so
arrogant that is the one thing I could
not get past Bernie Sanders the
arrogance of wanting to take my stuff I
was looking at him just seething over
this on the plane then landing in Canada
in a land of people who think they are
entitled to take your stuff and if you
say hold on hold on don't take my stuff
they call
the united states arrogant and you don't
need to feel guilty about that we got
people all the time well you know I
travel abroad and I'm afraid because
they they don't like Americans you know
why they don't like Americans because
they rely on us for everything from
medical innovations for national
security and then we say you know what
hey maybe it started it's time to start
paying for your own stuff maybe it's
time for you to start innovating maybe
it's time for you to start benefiting us
the rest of the world instead of us
entirely subsidizing you maybe it's time
to defend yourself can you believe how
arrogant the Americans are yeah in that
sense I am so proud of American
arrogance because I've seen the
arrogance from Quebec and Montreal I
haven't been there in a decade I went
back and it broke my heart because
socialism creates an entirely soulless
people it sucks the life out of you and
I saw broken shells of men and women who
I used to know and he can just see it
beats them down the United States is the
only place where that doesn't happen
anymore there still is some hope thank
God for it guess that's arrogant see you
next week
[Music]